(elegant orchestral music)
- I didn't bring you here
just to sip some tea,
I wanted to spill some tea.
So, I thought of a game.
I like to call it "Sip It and Spill It"
and it's basically a very sophisticated
version of Never Have I Ever.
So, I'll start.
Because there's something I'm
actually very interested in,
and I've never seen a ghost,
and I wanna see a ghost,
and I'm very mad that I haven't.
Have you ever been scared by
the Highclere Castle ghost?
(rock guitar)
Okay, you're sipping.
- I haven't been scared by it,
but put it this way:
when Shirley MacClaine
was on the show,
Oh, of course, Shirley...
she of course has probably lived at
Highclere Castle in the past.
(group laughing)
And she said he's been
in this room before.
He's been sat there having dinner.
So I think that's one step
removed from being in touch...
- Oh my gosh.
- She was there the day
before we were filming though,
wasn't she?
- Yeah!
- This is why I love her,
she's slightly nutty.
We have the same birthday,
I'm slightly nutty.
So yeah, Tauruses are all weird.
But yes, but we're fun, right?
All right, so anybody wanna go now?
Maybe Elizabeth, you wanna go?
- Sip it and spill it if you have
a DJ alter-ego at this table.
- A DJ alter-ego.
What!?
What, what?
- Okay, so.
- Tell us more!
- I'm always that person at a party.
I get all the tunes going and everything,
and my Spotify playlist
is called DJ Doggard's.
However, that has recently been blown
out of proportion--
Escalated a bit.
- And apparently I'm spinning
the decks in Ibiza every year,
which is not true.
(group laughing)
- Okay Michelle, go ahead.
- Sip it and spill it if you're
related to Indiana Jones.
- Harrison Ford?
(chimes twinkling)
- What!?
- Ooh!
- My grandfather was an explorer,
and he was the first white
man to go into Tibet,
and he wrote a book
about it, and then he did
a whole bunch of exploring in his life,
and somebody on Google made up that he was
the inspiration for Indiana Jones.
- [Hugh] Oh, the real Indiana Jones.
- Yeah.
- That's way cooler than
the Harrison Ford thing.
I thought that was what happened.
I was like, "Oh, okay."
Cool, okay.
Harrison Ford!
- He's pretty cool.
- I still like you, Harrison.
- All right.
(group laughing)
- Sip it or spill it if you've ever
ridden a bicycle on a motorway.
(suspenseful drums)
(twinkling chimes)
- What?
I wanna be friends with you.
- I decided to shake it up a little,
and instead of taking the
car to the dance rehearsal,
I would ride my bike
to the dance rehearsal.
And everything was going
well, and I had my helmet on,
and I was going, and I went
up this little slip road,
suddenly they were like
(cars whooshing)
and I was riding
Oh my God.
- I was on a freeway.
- [Kelly] Whoa.
- I had taken a wrong turn.
- [Kelly] And you were
going the opposite way?
- And I was like, "F--"
(car horns beeping)
(group laughing)
- [Kelly] And you weren't--
- Like this, and everyone
was honking at me.
It was like, terrible, dream.
And I was just trying to
get to my dance rehearsal.
I was like, "I'm just going
to the dance rehearsal!"
And then, I finally, I finally
got off the next off-ramp,
made it to the, I came into the rehearsal.
I was-- sweat, literally
pouring down my face, sweat.
(grunting)
These two.
- We just look at the door,
she was there, like--
You would never let
me forget it.
- "Never again."
(men laughing)
- I mean, look at him.
- Wait, you're hilarious.
Were you going the opposite way
then, of all the other cars?
- Ah, I don't remember which way I was--
- She was heading for Heathrow.
- Okay, it was like--
- I don't have a great sense of direction.
- I don't either.
- Really!?
- I don't.
You have no sense of direction.
- There's nothing you can do about it.
- I'm you.
I would've been the one lost
for three hours in the dark.
- Do you know, I went for a walk--
- [Michelle] She went for a walk!
- I went for a little
walk on Highclere Castle.
- She went, "I'm just gonna go for a walk"
during the lunch break.
And then it was getting closer and closer
to the time we needed to go on set.
- We couldn't--
- You went on a hike!
- We couldn't find her.
- I'm you, I get lost very easily.
I don't know if I've ever gotten on a road
with a bicycle.
Can you imagine
some of the people on that road?
- What they must have thought.
- Especially if they notice you.
- Suddenly they're like, "Is that lady--"
- "Do I know her?"
- That's the best part!
Okay, okay okay.
I do want to talk about though,
let's talk about the movie, though.
Everybody's so excited about it.
- This really deserves to
be seen on a big screen
because it's so much more
sort of lush and vibrant
and epic than we had even on the TV show,
which in itself was quite cinematic.
And I think that's the major difference.
I think fans who've followed the show
from the beginning will be delighted
that it's a continuation of the story,
and even for people who don't know
the characters and the series,
it's a stand-alone story.
And it was really the support
of the fans that drove it,
that got us all back together, because
I think if that appetite hadn't been there
from the fans, then we
wouldn't be sitting here now
at your lovely tea table.
- All right, sip it and spill it
if you've had the
greatest time ever at the
most amazing--
Yay! Cheers to that!
- Oh!
- We never do that!
Well, you do in America, Hugh.
- Oh, just sip it and stop it, Hugh.
(Kelly laughing)
(orchestral finale)